ahora vamos a ver mi forma favorita para
invertir matrices y bueno no te enseñe
esta forma desde el principio porque en
la clase de álgebra yo me acuerdo que te
enseñan la otra forma primero y a veces
ni siquiera te enseñan esta pero a mí me
gusta muchísimo más esta porque es más
difícil equivocarse haciendo errores de
cuentas y todo eso es mucho más rápido y
van a ver que está bien bonito pero
bueno así y no te voy a enseñar porque
funciona desde el principio siempre en
matemáticas es súper importante saber
por qué funcionan las cosas qué es la
maquinaria que está detrás de todo lo
que hacemos pero en este caso en
particular te voy a enseñar primero cómo
se hacen las cosas y después en algún
otro vídeo te voy a enseñar por qué
funciona lo que estamos haciendo porque
es muchísimo más sencillo en este caso
en particular no siempre generalmente es
al revés pero en este caso es muchísimo
más fácil saber exactamente qué pasos se
tienen que seguir y poder hacerlos
perfectamente para invertir matrices y
después de entender y conocer
perfectamente por qué funcionan esos
pasos
pero bueno vamos a empezar vamos a usar
exactamente la misma matriz del vídeo
pasado la cual era la matriz 1 0 1 0 2 1
y 1 1 1 y lo que vamos a hacer es la
eliminación de gauss orden hand que va a
sonar un poquito como vudú o sea o sea
tal vez no va a hacer nada claro porque
funciona pero más adelante vas a ver
vídeos que expliquen perfectamente por
qué funciona y además es súper útil y
súper fácil y súper bonito aunque hay
entonces lo que hacemos en la
eliminación del caos orden es que
aumentamos esta matriz y bueno a mí si
me gusta ponerle una línea que divide a
la matriz original de lo que yo le voy a
aumentar de este lado pero no todas las
personas le ponen esa línea entonces de
este lado del lado izquierdo de nuestra
raya vamos a dejar la matriz tal cual
como estaba tal cual como nos la dieron
la matriz de la cual queremos encontrar
la matriz inversa
el lado derecho vamos a poner una matriz
identidad del mismo tamaño que la matriz
que tenemos aquí a la izquierda ok
esta es la matriz identidad de 3 por 3
porque aquí tenemos una matriz de 3 por
3 entonces necesitamos la matriz de 3
por 3 lo que vamos a hacer es una serie
de operaciones elementales de fila y
estoy a punto de decirte cuáles son las
operaciones elementales de fila válidas
para hacer la eliminación de cada orden
pero bueno vamos a hacer estas
operaciones elementales de fila a toda
la fila ok vamos a estar pensando nada
más en esta matriz pero cada que le
hagamos una operación a alguna de estas
filas de esta matriz vamos a hacerle
exactamente lo mismo a esta matriz de
acá
ok como si ésta le estuviera copiando
cada uno de sus movimientos a esta
matriz y el chiste la meta lo que vamos
a tratar de hacer nosotros es hacer que
esta matriz se vuelva a la matriz
identidad y lo que nos va a quedar de
éste
una vez que hagamos que esta matriz sea
la matriz identidad si realmente
seguimos al pie de la letra cada uno de
los movimientos que hacemos en esta
matriz cuando aquí haya una matriz
identidad de este lado lo que vamos a
tener es la matriz inversa de la matriz
que teníamos originalmente en este lado
entonces tal cual lo que hacemos es con
esta matriz imitar los movimientos que
hagamos en esta matriz y hacer los
movimientos necesarios como para que en
esta matriz haya puros unos en la
diagonal y ceros en el resto de las
entradas o sea la matriz identidad
usando únicamente las operaciones
elementales de fila válidas que ahorita
vamos a ver cuáles son bueno para
empezar una de las operaciones
elementales de fila que sí podemos hacer
es tal cual tomar una de estas filas
recuerda que tenemos que tomar toda la
fila para que esta matriz esté imitando
a esta matriz y en multiplicar toda la
fila por una constante ok de hecho
podemos pensar en que tomamos la fila
reemplazamos por esta misma fila
multiplicada por esta constante
también puede tomar cualesquiera de
estas dos filas e intercambiarlas de
lugar sea por ejemplo puede tomar esta
fila y esta fila e intercambiar las de
lugar o sea tomar toda la fila morada y
ponerla como si fuera la primera fila o
sea en el lugar de la verde y tomar la
fila verde y ponerla en el segundo lugar
o sea en lugar de la fila morada pero
que no se te olvide que tienes que mover
toda la fila o game siempre es muy común
que se nos olvide mover a estos
numeritos de acá y eso es algo que no
nos tiene que pasar porque arruinamos el
proceso y la última operación que nos
falta es tomar toda una fila
y restarse la a otra de las filas
o lo que es lo mismo agarrar una fila y
reemplazarla por esa fila menos alguna
otra de las filas o más alguna otra de
las filas bien entonces ya tenemos
nuestra lista de operaciones de fila
elementales
entonces ya estamos listos ya tenemos
todas las herramientas para tratar de
transformar esta parte de la matriz en
la matriz identidad y bueno para usar
los términos correctos aunque estén
complicados y rebuscados y todo eso esto
de transformar esta matriz en la matriz
identidad o tratar lo mejor que podamos
de transformarla en la matriz identidad
es a lo que formalmente le llamamos
transformar esta matriz a su forma
escalonada reducida por filas entonces
ahora sí vamos
si está afuera o la matriz identidad
aquí tendría que haber un ser o no
entonces vamos a empezar por convertir
esto en un 0 y como vamos a hacer eso
pues a mí se me ocurre que vamos a usar
la operación elemental que agarra esta
primera fila y se la resta a esta última
fila aunque hoy vamos a reemplazar esta
última fila por esta fila menos la
primera fila y bueno esta operación no
le está haciendo absolutamente nada a
las primeras dos filas entonces pues
vamos a empezar por escribirlas
1 0 1 1 0 0 0 2 1
10 y ahora si la verdad la verdad lo que
queremos es que haya un 0 0 1 pero pues
vamos a empezar por hacer que aquí haya
un 0 entonces tomamos esta fila y le
restamos esta fila y entonces lo que nos
queda es uno menos uno eso sí es un cero
que es lo que queríamos
1 - 0 eso es un 11 menos 1 eso es un 0
ok ahora muy importante que no se nos
olvide a esta otra parte también le
tenemos que restar esta parte ok
entonces
0 - 1 eso es menos 10 menos 0 0
1 - 0 1 listo ya realizamos nuestra
primera operación elemental de fila y
aquí estas 3 entradas se ven super
parecidas a lo que nosotros necesitamos
que haya en la segunda fila no sea
porque queremos hacer que esta matriz
sea la matriz identidad o sea sea
igualita a esta cosa de aquí y aquí ya
tenemos una de las filas ya tenemos el 0
10 entonces lo que vamos a hacer ahora
es intercambiar estas dos filas del
lugar para que nos quede en la segunda
fila tal cual lo que ya tenemos que
entonces pues vamos a hacer eso esta es
otra de las operaciones elementales de
fila que si podemos hacer
ok la primera fila dejándolo tal cual es
1 0 1 1 0 0
ahora entonces estamos cambiando al
segundo lugar a esta fila y estamos
poniendo y estamos poniendo hasta abajo
a esta fila entonces en la segunda fila
tenemos 0
0 - 101 y hasta abajo en la tercera fila
pues tenemos lo que antes estaba en la
segunda fila no entonces tenemos 0 2 1 0
a 0 ok esta fue otra de nuestras
operaciones elementales pero todavía no
hemos terminado o sea aquí necesitamos
que haya una matriz identidad entonces
pues ahora necesitamos poner un cero en
este lugar y en este lugar entonces
vamos a seguir haciendo que haya un cero
por acá y para hacer eso lo más fácil es
tomar esta fila la fila verde a quad y
restarle dos veces la fila morada esta
fila aunque entonces nosotros vamos a
multiplicar toda la fila por un escalar
el escalar 2 y restárselo a esta fila
y entonces aquí tenemos 0 menos dos por
cero y eso es 0 - 0 o sea 0 y después
tenemos 2 menos 2 por 1
o sea 2 - 2 eso es 0 también y luego un
1 menos 2 por 0
1 - 0 esto es un 1 y qué maravilla ya
tenemos aquí otra fila tal cual como lo
tenemos que poner entonces ya tenemos
estas dos filas tal cual como tienen que
estar ya nada más nos falta arreglar
este detalle y que no se me olvide que
aquí en el resto de esta fila también le
tengo que restar dos veces esta fila y
entonces es cero menos dos por este
valor o sea 0 - 2 x
- 1 - 1 ok
aquí este menos con este menos se va a
cancelar y nos va a quedar un 2 que
entonces aquí va un 21 menos 2 por 0
eso es
0 - 2 x 1 0
2 - 2 y listo pero todavía nos falta
esta entrada y para arreglar esta
entrada para hacer que esta entrada sea
0 para que ahora si hayamos reducido
esta matriz a su forma escalonada
reducida por filas o sea que lo hayamos
convertido a lo más parecido que podamos
en la matriz identidad vamos a tomar
esta fila y le vamos a restar una vez
esta fila
entonces esta fila menos una vez esta
fila 10 10 - 0
1 - 10 que es justo lo que queríamos
1 - 2 eso es menos uno menos 10 menos
uno eso es menos 10 - menos 2 eso es 12
y ahora si estas dos pilas ya están tal
cual como tienen que estar
y listo ya está ya logramos reducir la
matriz izquierda a la matriz identidad
haciendo un montón de operaciones de
fila elementales ok entonces esta es la
matriz identidad bueno pero hoy ahora
qué demonios es esto que está por acá
bueno pues resulta que si a esta matriz
con la que empezamos la matriz original
le llamamos la matriz a si hicimos todo
lo que teníamos que ser muy bien
entonces esta matriz de por acá es la
matriz
inversa está maravilloso no y nos damos
la mitad del tiempo que nos tardamos
usando el otro método que usaba la
matriz de cofactores y la matriz adjunta
y el determinante y todo ese desmadre o
sea fue mucho más rápido y hicimos
cuentas muchísimo menos complicadas o
sea aquí yo siento que uno se equivoca
muchísimo menos haciendo las cuentas y
bueno eso de por qué funciona pues te
voy a dar una idea de por qué funciona
justo ahorita resulta que cada una de
estas operaciones de fila elementales
tienen su propia matriz
le llaman matrices elementales que hacen
que por ejemplo llegar a una matriz y la
multiplicas por esta matriz elemental
entonces eso es igual a por ejemplo
intercambiar dos filas de lugar o tomar
una fila y restarse la otra fila o tomar
una fila y multiplicar la por un escalar
ok para cada una de esas operaciones
elementales de fila existe una matriz
que si multiplicamos cualquier matriz
por esa matriz entonces se cambian las
filas del lugar o se hace alguna de esas
operaciones de fila elementales pero
bueno el chiste en este vídeo no es
enseñarles cuáles son esas matrices
elementales eso tal vez lo veamos en
algún vídeo más adelante ok entonces en
este proceso de convertir esta matriz en
la matriz identidad lo que hicimos como
hicimos puras operaciones elementales
fue tomar por ejemplo la matriz
y multiplicarla para pasar de aquí acá
la multiplicamos por llamémosle no sé a
uno a la matriz elemental que hace que a
la tercera fila le restemos la primera
fila no y después para pasar de aquí a
acá lo que hicimos fue multiplicar por
otra matriz elemental pues no se
podríamos llamarlo por ejemplo ese 2
esta matriz lo que hace es intercambiar
la segunda fila con la tercera fila y
después multiplicamos a todo este
producto que teníamos ya por otra matriz
que lo que hacía es a esta fila a la
tercera fila restarle dos veces la
segunda fila 3 es esa matriz y
finalmente multiplicamos por la última
matriz elemental que a la primera fila
le resta una vez la tercera fila
y así obtuvimos la matriz identidad ok
entonces a por uno por ese dos por el 3
por el 4 esta multiplicación de matrices
resultó ser la matriz identidad
pero como ya hemos visto si una matriz
la multiplicamos por otra matriz y nos
da la matriz identidad entonces esa
matriz que en este caso es toda esta
multiplicación de matrices juntas esa
matriz resulta ser la matriz inversa la
matriz a la menos 1 ok entonces ya
tenemos que la multiplicación de el 1
por ese 2 por el 3 por el 4 es la
inversa ahora qué es lo que pasa aquí
pues que teníamos a la matriz a y
estamos separando la por una raya de la
matriz identidad ok pero a esta matriz
identidad a esta matriz le hicimos
exactamente las mismas operaciones de
fila que a la matriz ósea para pasar de
aquí a acá también le restamos la
primera fila
tercera fila ok entonces también a esta
matriz identidad la multiplicamos por la
matriz elemental
uno por uno y después también cambiamos
del lugar
estas dos filas aunque yo sé que también
la multiplicamos por ese 2 y lo hicimos
todos los mismos cambios que a la matriz
a aunque hay entonces aquí la estuvimos
multiplicando por las mismas matrices
elementales pero si esto resulta ser la
matriz inversa a la hora de
multiplicarlo por la matriz identidad
pues lo que nos queda es simplemente la
matriz inversa la matriz a inversa está
muy bonito no y además estuvo súper
sencillo
bueno nos vemos en el próximo vídeo